So we have talked about buffer
overflows and how programs that have
this vulnerability can get exploited, in
particular letting attackers or giving
them the ability to execute arbitrary
code with the host services privileges.
It's not a good thing.
We shouldn't write code that
has those vulnerabilities, but
if such code is out there deployed
on systems, we need to find ways to
defend against attacks that are going to
exploit these kind of vulnerabilities.
So we're going to talk
about a number of defenses
that help us counter attacks that
rely on these buffer overflows.
The first one we're going to talk about
is your choice of programming language.
What language are you
writing your program in?
There are actually going to be languages
where this kind of problem goes away,
you don't have buffer overflows.
And these languages are languages
that are strongly typed, that do lot
of memory management they do automatic
automatically, so they do bounds check.
Remember one of the problems that we had
was that we declared a string variable
of size 12 and
we said you can read any amount into it.
There is no way unless I
explicitly inserted a check,
the language didn't do that, unless I
explicitly inserted a check that said
giving it more than 12 bites,
that's not good.
The language didn't
stop me from clobbering
whatever was next to
the password string that we had.
Not all languages do that.
There are languages that say you
have an object of size this,
this is how much it could be,
it can't be any more.
So what type of variable it is,
how much memory is required for
it or is allocated to it, and how much
memory you can access when you access
that variable, this bounds
check that we're talking about.
And if you manage this
memory automatically,
the problem of memory overflow,
or abusing memory the way we did when we
have buffer overflows, that goes away.
So, languages that do
are called safe languages,
because you can rely on type safety and
you don't make these kind of mistakes.
So there are several examples of these
languages, Java, C++, and others.
So if you write code in these kind of
languages that have type safety and
that do the kind of things
that we're talking about,
buffer overflow would not be a problem.
The buffer overflow typically
comes because we don't do
either strong type checking or this
bounds checks that I was talking about,
which is what low level kind of
languages are notorious for that.
But these object oriented strongly typed
languages make that problem go away.